[Music]
well here's the deal for years Anna has
been trying to get her husband to make a
cameo on our hit CBS sitcom mom well
Thursday night it's finally happening
and we have your exclusive first look
try an apple I would have given it to
the horse but that's another way to go
this is the most fun of it I think I've
ever had on a set I it's really nice to
see your spouse in their work
environment well I don't know if it is
for everyone but it is for me it's his
first TV role since the Parks and Rec
series finale in 2015 and a guest spot
on mom was on his bucket list being her
guest on Fridays when they would take
part of me always was a little jealous
that I couldn't be out there on that
stage with them hi I'm Marjorie hi NIC
aunt Marjorie how she signs my birthday
cards it's also Chris's first time
performing in front of a live studio
audience
when the audience is responding you you
land a joke made a laugh and it just it
just fills you with energy in the
episode Chris plays a horse trainer who
catches the eye of Christie where have
you been hiding him
and why is he single put him in a
flannel shirt and a give him some reins
in his hand and you're like giddyup
let's go this isn't the first time Chris
and Anna have starred together on screen
they've co-starred in three movies
falling for each other in 2007 while
filming their first take me home tonight
this is a big step but I think it's the
right thing no yes two years later they
tied the knot and now have a
four-year-old son Jack they have a great
chemistry together off and on camera and
it's been all of us are just like oh we
get to that like have this really nice
relationship we have a sex scene like a
sexy scene been rehearsing that for 10
years
you